tu finiras dans un laboratoire fous-toi
ça dans le crâne
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire là
autant que tu crois
on
travaille avec des années que je suis
sur votre race qu'est-ce que je fais là
je veux la formule contenue dans ton
sein quelle formule celle qui permet
d'activer ou d'annuler tes pouvoirs
quel est le véritable pouvoir
faire croire aux autres ce que l'on veut
qu'il croit tout en restant dans
l'endroit
faut pas rester là tu sais boxer
[Musique]
on a plus le temps
avec moi
[Musique]
c'était qui cet homme un percepteur
il peut générer des illusions visuelles
comme toi mais c'est pouvoir ne
s'arrêtent pas là c'est le plus puissant
de tous ceux auxquels nous ayons été
confrontés tout ce qui te rend différent
fait ta force
personne
t'as été fouillé dans ma caboche je veux
savoir ce que je suis nous sommes un
produit Yann
tu n'es pas le seul
[Musique]
grâce à cette formule ecoute pas ce
qu'elle dit nous développons certaines
capacités extrasensorielles
et tu crois que je vais avalé c'est
bobard